[Music]
Bob if I can call you Bob that is your
name you're writing a book about your
life and and I'm hoping cuz I'll be the
first in line to get that book that
there'll be some full house stories in
there that are behind the scenes and
scandalous and they're nothing cuz
you're a you have a dirty mind you know
well you do he does I'm not I'm telling
you the truth
I think everybody does kind of accept oh
not like you not like you made it oh
yeah you're a good guy but you you're
I'm ghosts sometimes to journey places
I'm picturing you both in a hotel room
right now I'm just kind of reg like a
Hydra because that gets whatever it's
happening later but you were doing that
you said you're kind of tangent remember
any of that anyway so yeah doing a
sitcom for family stuff has residuals
with me and in the book I'm actually
writing about a live donkey on the show
once which people might have seen that
episode I forgot it I was like I don't
know on nyquil or something that year
but um Whittle I was an episode of full
house where there's a donkey on this
alive donkey called a or which was a
great name to come up with it yeah
and then the donkey with a studio
audience and it was like full air
conditioning and stuff I don't know if
this has ever happened here but the
donkey
gotten excited in front of the audience
and it got an erection you know in front
of them I don't know if it's ever
happened here yes and you get that
animals here you have a desk so no one
would know
that's what I
there's a reason this thing is bolted
down
I I am dirty apparently I am dirty yeah
no no not at all so far so let's talk
about so that it's not about the donkey
erection
[Laughter]
well it got it got aroused and I'd know
what to do because there were kids there
the kids were younger and John Stamos
handsome yogurt man and like he's like a
sister to me and yeah and Dave Dave Dave
Coulier the other friend was Joey at we
were standing there and the kids were
young I don't know what to do so I
started to call the thing Peppermill
instead of E or because it it looked
like you know when you go to Olive
Garden and you get fresh ground pepper
yeah looked like the whole it looked
like a pepper mill looked like a pepper
mill you know I said so saying that so
to defuse the situation around children
yes you started yelling pepper mill
pepper man cuz I cuz I wanted to help
the children
yeah and protect them sure but this this
is what it's in the book stuff like that
that stayed with me cuz I'll this is a
true thing I will be in a restaurant and
I'll get a Caesar salad and the guy will
come over and he'll go would you like
some fresh ground pepper and I'll just
get that thing away from me that is that
is a that is a donkey's okay what are
you doing
[Applause]
you got you got audio people they can do
thing I know we can't afford to do that
that's going out to all the nerd